This course is also really built
around the idea of mentorship.
We have a team of TAs, but
more than teaching assistants and
more than graders,
they're really meant to be mentors for
you as you go through this course.
Every mentor will have a small group of
students that they'll interact with on
a weekly basis.
You'll have the same mentor
review all your assignments,
review your project proposal.
Review all your status
reports on that project and
review the final deliverable.
They're really meant to get
a familiarity with your interests,
your project idea, and your progress.
In fact,
when we reach the end of the semester,
if you decide to keep your project going
as a research agenda or a startup,
I wouldn't be surprised if your
mentor even became a partner for you.